it's june 2nd which means it's a day
after june 1. that is some high-level
analysis that you only get here
and what what it used to mean pre-2006
would be a second wave of free agency
and for the first five years or so
that we operated pft it was always a big
day on the calendar because
there would be players who were under
contract
who had bloated cap numbers who had
bonus amounts that if they were cut
before june 1
would rush onto the cap and you had to
wait until after june 2 because
after june 2 you would only take
the bonus acceleration the bonus
allotment that applies for this year
you don't get any acceleration anything
that's left over went to the next year
so
there was a cottage industry within the
cottage free agency industry of
june 2 june 2 june 2. guys get cut
other teams then pursue them and it
created ten weeks
to or ten days excuse me to two weeks of
content yeah
right right 2006 had all changed and it
created the device that allows teams
to cut two players per year before
june one and treat it like it's a post
june one transaction
so like a kyle rudolph he would have
been cut today
pre-2006 kyle rudolph was cut by the
vikings
back in march it's processed as a post
june 1 transaction
so that part of it's done but this year
chris yeah
june 2 is making a comeback because
and it used to be if you traded a guy
during any year at any time
before or after june 1 you took the full
salary cap acceleration that year
they decided and i think it was around
the same time if not a couple of years
later they decided
that if you trade someone after june 1
treats it the same way so
that's why we've been talking about
julio jones being traded
as of june 2. the russell wilson angle
39 million
cap charge drops to 13 million right as
of june 2. that 26 million doesn't
disappear it just hits the cap next year
so so this year we're not looking at
june 2 as a potential
launch point for guys to get cut
although it still could happen
it's a launch point for guys to get
traded starting with julio jones
but the other names that have been
percolating desean watson aaron rodgers
russell wilson those trades if they
happen now
all entail much more favorable cap
consequences for their current team so
not not that it's it's
going to make something that's not
happen happen but it makes it more
palatable for the team that's trading
the player yeah it's part of a
it's part of the world we live in right
now with the nfl you're right and it is
it's a device that you know you did a
good job explaining it there you really
did because i think a lot of people kind
of know
a little bit oh yeah june 2nd or june
1st you could
you know cut the you know cut it in half
like you talk about but i don't think
people really know the details
or anything like that so uh yeah it's it
takes a little burden off the team here
and we'll see maybe we see a little more
action the only one right now
on the radar though that i think is like
really really relevant that we think
could happen
right unless i'm missing somebody else
because you named all the big names is
julio right there's nobody else right
now we're literally looking at that's
uh that type of scenario but
but as i said last week you can't
completely rule out the possibility like
you know a team such as the raiders
plotting and waiting to make a move as
of june 2 to try to get russell wilson
and and if it's something that and again
we don't know and they're never going to
tell us
let's say that john gruden's not happy
with
derek carr yeah he's not going to come
out and say it at this stage of the
season
you know you yeah yeah you know derek
dirk carr you know we've been doing this
for three years we got to do something
big
and at some point in may they decide
hey once this window opens for the
seahawks to take 26 million
less of a cap charge let's go make them
a big offer and see what they do
and if they take it then it happens like
a lightning bolt nobody saw it coming
just like nobody saw the
san francisco 49ers trading from 12 to 3
coming until it happened and
so it makes it slightly less
unattractive i'm not saying it makes it
more attractive because the seahawks
don't seem to be inclined to do it yeah
but
you you we have removed that well they
can't do it they take a 39 million
dollar cap
right that's what as of today they would
take 13.
and and it's and it's 13 versus 39
because there's 39 left
at 13 million a year for the next three
years so this year's number is 13
they're taking that whether he's on the
team or not it was that other 26 that
was in the balance
and now that other 26 goes to next year
and so that makes it easier
aaron rodgers 11 and a half million
dollars yeah of
potential cap charge gone now for desean
watson yeah what's that point
two million 16.2 million is what the
texans
would realize in savings this year by
trading them now
they still have to take it next year but
it reduces the cap hits so
those are the guys who were relevant
post june 2
and any player who would get traded who
would have remaining cap acceleration
beyond this year
that that's that's the bonus that's the
inducement
to letting a guy be traded after june 2
and
you know we'll we'll see if that results
in any of the guys other than julio
jones
being more likely to be traded but for
jones there was no way it was a
non-starter he was not getting traded
before june 2. and
you know chris the betting odds i don't
know if you saw this last night i don't
know if we talk about it later in the
show i did
read the the you know the outline of the
show but now i forget whether or not
it's in there
right uh the seahawks now the betting
favorites which i would not make that
bet
i would not make that bet if if uh if
given the opportunity
and sufficiently willing to squander my
money i would not bet on the seahawks i
would still bet on the titans to be the
team that gets him yeah
i mean i'd be surprised if they were the
team that got him too
i would i mean especially with like the
uncertainty of where
russell wilson is right now and and his
standing with the seattle seahawks and
all of that
you know the things we brought up with
julio jones yesterday
you know of course we know you know
practicing isn't always the easiest he
does do a little bit load management
during the year as far as how much he
practices when he practices
and then the contract situation i don't
know that just doesn't seem like a
seattle move to me i
it does not and if they did make that
move
i don't know i guess maybe it would
maybe maybe make me change my thought
about what they want to do with russell
wilson i guess
that's the one thing i will say right
you'd go okay absolutely they're not
going to trade them after the year
they're going to do everything they can
to make this work and extend
them and they're going to try to get one
more run out of this another four or
five year run out of russell wilson
and see if they can do it okay so you're
in agreement there
trading for russell wilson in seattle
would have the same impact on the
relationship with russell wilson as
trading for
uh for julio jones you know trading for
julio jones in seattle would have the
same
impact on the relationship with the
quarterback as it would have in
greenback yeah right
and we we advocated early on when the
julio jones trade talk accelerated
this is something the packers could do
and in one fell swoop
fix their issue with aaron rodgers
same thing applies to the seahawks which
is one of the reasons why we don't think
they're going to do it
like all of a sudden the seahawks after
years of you just work here
you don't need to tell us what to do
right we're going to run the team the
way we see
fit ground to pound ground and pound oh
wait you know what we got an idea
we're gonna go three wide we're gonna go
dk metcalf
tyler lockett julio jones right let's go
right fire up the office yeah there you
go russell wilson you're now our patrick
mahomes we've
we we have seen the light yeah right we
are ready to do this
i think that to the extent that it's
true there have been trade discussions
it was done so they can just say to
russell wilson
we tried maybe that's the only reason
they did it maybe
maybe that's why they did it you kind of
said that last year with antonio brown a
little bit too i mean maybe
maybe that is the reason they're doing
it uh but i'm with you it just
does not make sense for all the things
that you just kind of
you know sarcastically explained oh yeah
yeah we're gonna go all
russell and throw the ball and throw the
ball oh wait you threw two interceptions
hey bring in the other tight end and
we're going to run the ball for five
straight weeks now hey julio
uh we don't need you we have the other
two receivers on the field yeah
that's where i don't think it makes
sense for seattle at least
i don't you know yeah they got enough
issues there right now
they got the jamal adams contract on the
horizon they got the dk metcalf contract
on the horizon
tyler lockett's what on a five-year 90
million dollars got a new contract right
so i just don't see any of that adding
up to seattle making a move for julio
and that's really the point that hasn't
been emphasized nearly enough julio
jones is not just going to show up and
say hey you got me for the next three
years at 38 million
he may want a new contract now he
definitely will want one if he has a big
year in 2021
and after 2021 that's when dk metcalf
is in line to get his it's just it's a
problem that the seahawks
shouldn't want and i wouldn't want and
look i think the seahawks need to solve
their russell wilson problem one way or
the other
but you don't solve that problem by
taking on
another problem that just compounds your
total
player personnel problems yeah having
julio jones on the roster just creates
more problems and it solves i believe
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports